Let's try.
Why don't we go to Sam from Princeton, Massachusetts,
not Princeton, New Jersey.
Yes, I can, so I'll preface this by saying
I sort of realized that this isn't exactly
the type of priorities right now, OK, but
I was just on Twitter before I came in this
lobby and I'm seeing there's lawmakers in
sort of some sort of congressional meeting.
And I've seen it going on a little bit, talking
about trans people in athletics and sort of
legislating that process.
Now I'm on the left.
I consider myself to be ardently pro trans
rights and everything.
But it does at the same time seem pretty deeply
unfair to me that to allow, you know, people
who are born just biologically different to,
for example, trans women to participate in
men's sports and women's sports.
Yeah, but I mean, listen, it sounds like we
have the same view I've talked about this
before, which is I have a problem with people
that pretend like this is the big issue, the
big injustice that's going on.
And it sounds like you're saying the same
thing.
You recognize this is not like the biggest
issue.
At the same time, when I think about a sport
like weightlifting or wrestling and I think
about someone born biologically male and then
saying, well, they now that they identify
as as a woman and they're going to participate
in wrestling or weightlifting, it strikes
me as not making complete and total sense.
And this does not in any way affect the fact
that I believe trans folks should be able
to live lives free of discrimination.
They should be included in protections when
it comes to employment and should be able
to have a license that reflects their gender
as as they want to exist in the world.
And yet it just doesn't.
I just don't understand how you say, well,
someone born biologically male can participate
in women's wrestling.
I don't I don't get it.
I get that.
You're not saying it's the most important
issue.
Neither am I.
It's not even the most important issue within
trans rights to me.
There are so many more important issues with
interest rates.
But yeah, I'm basically with you.
I would love somebody to explain it to me.
Yeah, I totally.
And the thing that sort of concerns me is
like I because I, I watch your show and I
watch other things too.
And the sense that I get is that I would be
called a transfer for that.
You know, I'm seeing people like in the majority
report and that sort of thing saying, you
know, that opinion people are sort of dunking
on like Tulsi Gabbard for having that opinion,
saying she's not really on the left.
And I was thinking, well, I mean, I don't
know if that's fair, you know?
Well, here's the thing.
I mean, the question is.
So I've said before how you can be in favor
of the movement to boycott Israeli products
and services without being anti-Semitic, but
it also is a great cover for lots of anti-Semitic
folks, much, much the same way you can have
this position or these questions about the
trans women's sports issues and be using it
as a cover for your transphobia or not.
You might be a staunch defender of trans rights
and anti trans discrimination and still have
that question.
So it's not a rule that that you are or are
not trans phobic because you are trying to
better understand this issue, as I am.
Right.
That's where I see myself.
So, yeah.
Anyway, thanks for taking my call.
All right.
My pleasure.
Appreciate the call very, very much.
That is all the time we have for today.
I apologize.
I was not able to get to everybody, but I
hope to be able to at some point in the future.